okay this is my favorite story of the  day - we love this story alright Gale  the University of Tennessee is taking  action after a young fan was bullied for  wearing a you t-shirt he designed  himself that's what he designed the  Florida fourth grader made this shirt  last week he really wanted to represent  his favorite school for college colors  day but he did not own any official  apparel his teacher posted his story on  Facebook after he was bullied for  wearing the shirt she found him crying  when UT found out the school decided the  turn his design into an official shirt  for the school they've already sold  14,000 shirts and the demand crashed a  website the University of Tennessee gave  him a bunch of swag he's invited to be  their official guest away they go thanks  Vlad